الى بريطانيا حيث افاده مراسلنا في لندن
ان شبكه السكك الحديديه تشهد اضطرابا
شديدا لليوم الخامس على التوالي بسبب
اضراب عشرات الالاف من العاملين في الشبكه
وفي شركات تشغيل القطارات
وقالت هيئه الجامعه لشركات تشغيل القطارات
انها قدمت عرضا بزياده في الاجور قدرها
اربعه في المئه لنقابه السائقين عن
العامين الجار والماضي قالت النقابه نهى
ستدرس العرض عندما تتلقاه بشكل رسمي كما
تشهد بريطانيا اضرابا اخر اليوم للعاملين
في اداره الطرق السريعه في مناطق عده رئيس
الحكومه
الى ما سماه حوارا عقلانيا يوما الاثنين
المقبل
انضم الينا من محطه قطارات لندن بريج في
لندن مراسلنا اسد الله صبري اهلا بك اسد
الله قل لنا مشاهداتك من هذه المحطه
وتاثير المباشر لهذا الاضراب على حركه
المسافرين
نحن الان في قلب محطه لندن برج احدى اكبر
محطات القطارات في العاصمه البريطانيه
الخدمه متاثره بشكل كبير بالاضراب في يومه
الخامس قطار واحد من كل خمسه تقريبا هو
الذي يعمل بالاضافه الى تخفيض عدد ساعات
عمل الخدمه اثنتي عشره ساعه فقط يوميا
بدلا من قرابه 19 او تسعه عشره ساعه يوميا
بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك الكثير من التاثير
والاضطراب في المواعيد كثير من القطارات
لا تتوقف في كل المحطات وكثير من القطارات
تاتي حتى متاخره عن مواعيدها هذه الموجه
من الاضطرابات بدات هذه المرحله بدات في
الثالث من يناير 40,000 من العاملين في
همم يعني خدمه شبكه الحديديه اضربه في
الثالث والرابع ثم في السادس والسابع من
يناير وفي الخامس اضرب سائق القطارات
عده 24 ساعه في الخامس من يناير وشالوا
حركه القطارات بنسبه 100% تقريبا في اكثر
مناطق بريطانيا هذه الموجه من الاضرابات
ربما كانت موجعه بشكل كبير لانها جاءت
ايضا بعد موسم الاعياد ونهايه العام هناك
الكثير من التفاؤل ربما بال الاجتماع
المتوقع يوم الاثنين المقبل الذي دعى اليه
رئيس الحكومه الريشي السوناك النقابات
المطربه ليس فقط نقابات همم السكك
الحديديه ولكن ايضا نقابات العاملين في
قطاعات اخرى كالصحه وامن الموانئ والمنافذ
وما الى ذلك همم التفاؤل مصدره ان الحكومه
ربما بدات تصغري ولكنها تدخل هذا الاجتماع
بعد ان رفعت عصا القوانين حذرت او حذر
وزير الاعمال قبل يومين من ان الحكومه
تنوي اصدار او تشريعه قوانين تحد من قدره
النقابات على الاضراب بل وتهدد بفصل
العاملين ومقاضاتهم ان لم يضمنوا حدا ادنى
من الخدمه اثناء اضرابهم وهو امر همم يعني
ترفضه النقابات بشده وتقول انه اجراء غير
ديمقراطي
من محطه قطارات لندن برج في لندن شكرا
جزيلا لك